Percy Potter and the sea of Secrets is
directed by hmm that's not the actual
title oh my bad
Percy Jackson in the Sea of Monsters is
directed by a dude named Thor I'm not
even kidding
who better to direct the movie featuring
characters from Greek mythology than a
guy named Thor I can't think of anyone
else Logan Lerman is back as Percy
Jackson and he is a half-blood he's
someone that God and a human made it and
created and you don't want to get too
much into the details of that because PG
him and his friends have to go out on a
quest to find the Golden Fleece which is
this thing that has the ability to heal
something that has died because this
tree that created a barrier around their
entire village has been poisoned and it
needs to be revived so they have to go
find the Golden Fleece to be able to
revive it otherwise their village is
open to attack from anything just now
sitting here I realized how complicated
that plot is the first one it did what I
had to do I didn't love it I didn't hate
it it was just you know it was Percy
Jackson this movie is pretty much just
like the first one it feels the same way
you watch it I think that younger teens
will probably have a lot of fun with
this movie for me it's just alright it's
an OK film with some okay CGI and some
ok action scenes and some ok moments and
it's an OK story it's just kind of there
I like Logan Lerman a lot he was great
in Perks of Being a Wallflower and he's
pretty good here but besides him and
maybe Stanley Tucci who's always kind of
cool as a supporting character he adds a
lot of humor into the movie I didn't
really think anyone else was very good
in this film especially his blond friend
she really got on my nerves in this
movie because her acting was so overly
serious and this is the kind of movie
that you want to have fun with and
you're not supposed to take the movie so
freaking seriously sometimes a movie
like this needs to be a little bit more
fun her performance just felt very
wooden and always with that very overly
serious like glaring look I just I don't
know it got on my nerves quite a bit but
I think my main problem with this movie
is that it just feels so unoriginal it
feels like so many different movies
mismatched into one it's got Harry
Potter in there it's got rate as a Lost
Ark in there especially this one finale
scene where this thing that looks
exactly like the Ark of the Covenant
with mist coming out of it and people
tied up as they watch it I was like this
is rain as a Lost Ark the main villain
in the film Luke this blond kid
completely wooden I don't buy him as a
villain at all there's some fun
sequences in the movie though it's not a
terrible movie at all there are some
times in the movie where I was into it
but the thing is the CGI feels so
cartoony and unrealistic it's really
hard to take any of it seriously there
are scenes in this movie where
characters are riding on this big horse
creature that looks cool but it just
looks so CGI like you're in a cartoon or
a green screen environment of some kind
also characters jump from scene to scene
to scene so quickly like all of a sudden
they're in a creature stomach and all of
a sudden there's a character there they
know and there's zombies and then all of
a sudden they're out of that and it just
it seems like everything just keeps
getting thrown to this one environment
after one environment and where some
films do that really well like say the
first Star Wars film from 1977 real
characters just keep ending up in these
big situations you really felt like you
were in the heat of the moment this
movie doesn't have that it doesn't feel
like you're in the moment I can see kids
really loving this film from like age
five up to age 1213 just diggin it and
loving every second of it but for the
most part this movie just feels like a
mishmash of other films that were better
already I'm gonna get Percy Jackson sea
of monsters a sea like I said it's not a
terrible movie I think it does what it
has to do fairly well for four kids but
it's just kind of a mediocre movie for
everyone who isn't really initiated with
this book series so guys what did you
think of the first film did you like it
do you like the book series are you
interested in this new one at all let me
know below guys and as always thanks
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
Oh